[Music]
hey guys the official trailer is finally
out it includes some scenes from the
first three episodes and mostly what we
already know about chiller begins with
Arya Stark in the hosts of NFL running
away from the whites that have at this
point breached Winterfell gates and
overcome all of Winterfell it's episode
three the battle for Winterfell then we
have Davos on the wall some NFL either
from the episode to ending or episode
three beginning Davos is in charge of
archers just as he was at the Battle of
the bastards
during the battle women children and
those who cannot fight will be in the
crypts of NFL but it might not be the
safest place to be at
since there are secret passages built
for the stark Lords so they could escape
in emergency and if theorists are sure
and if the night King was a stark it
probably no this [ __ ] passage and it
could lead into the crypts we also get
to see your own siren fleet filled with
the gun company that's coming to help
Cersei reaches Seven Kingdoms on a roll
this scene is from the season 8 premiere
and this is Cersei or seeing it
although this could also be the scene
where Cersei means just no leaf photos
confirmed they will meet and this
location seems to be the same as from
the leaked photos then we have berrykin
Thurman who just as I said went straight
to Castle black after destruction of the
east watch and reunited with Ted the
acting Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch gathered as many men as they could
and marched south this is the Mirai
being at either last heart or karhold
castles of how sombre and how scarce
dark both of which will be destroyed by
the night king they basically ride to
see nothing there are no dead nor lime
everyone who is defending it is now part
of the army of the Dead this is also
from the season 8 premiere here I assume
bran says the same that is better he is
the one to tell John the truth and Sam
tries to figure out the best way to
deliver such information this right here
is one of the opening scenes of season 8
with John and Danny passing through
winter town and arriving at Winterfell
beside John 10 in our midst of course
dragons arrive as well and census seems
to be just as impressed as our is the
symbol Long's in the episode two finale
John and Danny will be in the crypts of
NFL discussing Ned Stark
death and the de-spawn john knows who
your parents are then we have our
favorite blacksmith eater forging
weapons out of journalists or even
trying to forge brand-new Valyrian steel
swords now when they had both dragon
glass and dragon fire in which many
believe lies the secret to forging
Valyrian steel one or the other two are
the only substances capable of killing
the white walkers and they need it now
more than ever with the dead coming for
them
then we have Jorah commanding the
detraction lining them outside of
minerva when FL is not huge enough to
have all the arms inside and sins of the
track here horse riders is the best to
put them outside so they could try to
charge into and possibly outflank the
army of the Dead they would like to be a
company in with the Knights of the Vale
of course most of the unsullied will be
outside Winterfell as well they do not
ride horses but they fight in their
famous failings formation with large
groups of them fighting in lockstep
failing says using spear and shield
although they're also trained to use
short swords for close quarters combat
they will try to pull out the 3,000 of
Cora while defending winner fellow the
3,000 of korver the most famous and
solid cook held back at the track ich al
azhar or 50,000 strong back then 3,000
unsullied successfully held their ground
against the 50,000 the tracking now
there's around 7,000 unsullied and
they'll be facing a hundred thousand
strong army of the night King and here
great warm says goodbye to Islam is
sandy before going into battle here
Brienne fights on the walls of interval
Jaime also fights for the Starks and he
seems to be shouting something to
Brienne
then we are back at things Landing with
Cersei having a meeting with young
Greyjoy and later the golden company
here Strickland this is somewhere in the
mid that bestowed one and this shot is
from the end of episode 1 after sources
had a miscarriage
this was actually supposed to happen in
the season 7 finale but sure I decided
to rather have it in the season 8
premiere and here it is in case you
don't believe me there's one more proof
confirming it
notice that Cersei is drinking again
something she stopped doing ever since
she became pregnant services had a
miscarriage before fighting a Manor fell
Jamiel pledged to fight for the living
for the Starks this is from episode 1
and after days Jaime will get a stark
armor the same one Rob had the crown
will be fighting a Winterfell as well
and here we have John's seemingly
charging avoid walkers or even at the
night king himself the most interesting
clip from this trailer is John and Danny
approaching joke on a regal we know Dan
is obviously
- right Jorgen and seemingly John is as
well I think this might be Jamm
preparing to ride wiggle a dragon name
that release father ager
this could also be after the two have
learned that should behind Joshua
parentage and therefore sure that John
can be a dragon rider let me have some
more of Aria now not running but
fighting White's in her unique style
Syrio Forel would be proud then we have
this mysterious shadow Tyrion notice how
there is no snow around him and yet at
the end of season seven there's snow
everywhere from Winterfell to King's
Landing this right here might be the
only shot from the Game of Thrones
finale is he confirming some leaks
regarding his fade that we've had for a
few months now one would wonder but his
look does imply that things are not
going well for Tyrion this point and
right after that we have jog on burning
someone alive that's interesting in the
final shot we have the unsullied in the
Knights of the Vale we bring in Podrick
and sure evading for the knight king's
army to attack this is the episode three
opening scene there here guys detailed
breakdown of the first official trailer
for Game of Thrones Season eight many
Theory videos will come this day and
following days as well stay tuned and as
always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see you in the next one peace